this morning Treasury Secretary nominee
Steve Munchen and Energy Secretary Rick
Perry are the latest Trump picks to face
Senate questioning Senate Democrats
grilled the EPA nominees Scott Pruett
and HHS nominee Tom Price yesterday the
nominees for you an ambassador and
commerce secretary also testified and
sources tell CBS News the
president-elect has filled his last
cabinet vacancy he'll name former
Georgia governor sonny Perdue to be his
Secretary of Agriculture Nancy Cordes is
at the west front of the Capitol where
the inauguration will take place
tomorrow Nancy good morning good morning
and by the end of the day today Nora 15
of mr. Trump's nominees will have gone
before Congress and the fight right now
is over how many of them will be
confirmed tomorrow right after mr. Trump
takes the oath of office Democrats are
trying to slow the process they say they
have ethics concerns about some of them
including one who testified yesterday it
really begs credulity sir when you say
you did not know that you got a discount
on this this was a private offering
Senate Democrats cameras Georgia
congressman Tom Price over a stock deal
Wednesday you made the decision to
purchase that stock not a broker yes or
no that was a decision that I made yes
he purchased stock in a drug company at
a special price while helping form
legislation to speed drug approvals you
were notified of this trade on April 4th
2016 did you take additional actions
after that date to advance her plan to
help the company that you now own stock
in I'm offended by the insinuation
senator if confirmed as Secretary of
Health and Human Services price would
oversee any replacement to Obamacare you
may have an insurance card it may have a
wonderful name of an insurance company
on there but you don't have any care
because you can't afford the deductible
down the hall you're the Attorney
General
obviously you I've stood up and said you
will do everything you can to stop
future earthquakes as a result of
fracking senator I've acknowledged that
I'm concerned about the knowledge that
your concern
Democrats were also throwing punches
that Scott Pruett Oklahoma's Attorney
General if that's the kind of EPA
Administrator
you will be you're not going to get my
vote they argued that his long time ties
to energy companies will prevent him
from carrying out the core mission of
the Environmental Protection Agency
Pruitt said that's not the case this
paradigm that we live within today that
if you're Pro Energy you're
anti-environment if your parole
environment your anti Energy is
something that I think is just a false
narrative mr. Trump's pick for US
ambassador to the UN South Carolina
Governor nikki Haley also testified
yesterday she described NATO as vital
the same week that mr. Trump called it
obsolete and that Charlie has led some
European diplomats to say they are
confused about the position of the
incoming administration thanks Nancy